my name is Nora and I'm a partner
development manager on the Google Play
games team I'm very excited to be here
today because I get to speak about a
subject that I am very passionate about
and that's live operations and how live
ops can help you engage your gaming
communities to create long-term player
retention and value so to kick off our
agenda I'll start with a framework to
define live operations that way we're
all speaking with a common language then
I'll talk a little bit about why live
ops has become so important in today's
mobile gaming ecosystem but really you
shouldn't take my word for it and that's
why I've called in an expert Keith
Alexander the live ops manager for Kabam
smash hit Marvel contest of Champions
he'll be here to tell you about Marvel's
best-in-class live ops program and also
to give you a few tips for running
engaging live ops events in your games
so what is live ops and why is it
important put very simply live ops is
running games as a service this means
that your games become a living
breathing organic product that is
constantly changing given your new users
a brand new experience each and every
single day the goals of live ops are to
augment engagement stimulate
monetization and prevent player churn so
let's dig a little bit deeper into how
to actually achieve these goals as you
guys are already aware content is king
new content is what keeps your players
actively playing and actively spending
in your games the players who devote the
most time in your game become your loyal
fans and your best advocates these are
the players who have higher retention
rates and higher session frequency now
Kabam has lovingly coined these players
the regulars but for all you norm norm
Peterson fans out there anyone who knows
what cheers is is the norm feeders
high engagement and retention are key
the keys to creating long-term lifetime
value because in the world of mobile
gaming content is king and that means
that time on device equals money your
most active and engaged players are more
likely to have higher LTV curves so
another way to think about live ops is
the strategic distribution of content
through time limited sales and events
now when we talk about content in the
context of live ops we're not talking
about large apk updates and client-side
features it can be small server-side
changes for example adding a weekend
tournament or temporarily changing the
drop rates in a dungeon introducing a
brand-new hero character or a new piece
of legendary gear into your gaming
economy this new content is delivered in
mobile games through two different
channels sales and events when you sell
content through a Gacha or IEP bundles
you drive monetization metrics such as
new buyer conversion or ARPU but using
content as the chase prize in a
competitive event can help you drive
engagement metrics like login velocity
or session length making small
server-side changes to your game or
strategically Kaye dancing small pieces
of new content that are hidden within
your large apk updates keeps the player
experience fresh but why is all of this
important
Kabam CEO Kevin Chiu recently wrote an
article for game industry dot biz
describing the mobile game revenue curve
that he calls the shark fin this occurs
when a mobile game is released without a
consistent pipeline of content to keep
users busy as you guys know mobile
gamers love to consume content but they
also get bored really easily all your
new content is bundled into large apk
update
but releasing that content all at once
leads to rapid content consumption once
a player runs through all that new
content they eventually get bored and
then churn out of your game this means
that each of your new updates is
reaching fewer and fewer players and the
revenue bumps that you see from these
new updates diminish over time creating
these smaller and smaller shark fins in
his article
Kevin points to live ops as a way to
minimize this revenue degradation live
ops limited time sales and events can
help you slow roll the content held
within your large apk updates and
thereby helping you avoid the shark fin
and instead helps to drive a steady and
consistent heartbeat of revenue but it's
also important to note that live ops is
not about short-term revenue gains when
executed properly the strategy behind
live ops is to engage and retain your
users to create healthy long-term
lifetime value so to recap live ops is
running games as a service it's the
strategic distribution of content
through time limited sales and events a
consistent stream of new content will
help you augment engagement stimulate
monetization and prevent player churn
and finally a happy and engaged gaming
community drives consistent healthy
revenue along with higher LTV curves to
help you get the most out of your UA
budgets so by now you guys are probably
ready to see some real-world examples of
these engaging live ops events so it's
my pleasure to bring to the stage the
live ups manager for Kabam Marvel
contest of Champions Keith Alexander
Thank You Norah just getting your game
launched is a huge achievement often
after months and months of hard work but
you're going to have to keep it running
after day one well we'll keep the
players interested on day 30 day 60 a
year Marvel is reaching is two-year
anniversary next month and we have
mountains more content and events today
than we did when we launched we're lucky
to be working with Marvel an IP with
decades of history and a deep roster of
interesting characters and stories we
build many of our events to tie in with
current storylines or to create new ones
in collaboration with Marvel running
live ops is like continually adding to
the story some examples are the
characters we've created with Marvel
like guillotine civil warrior and venom
bull as well as the contest of Champions
comic book here are some examples of
past loading screens showing events
where characters featured in the game we
had a Civil War event between Iron Man
and Captain America over the summer we
added Loki who was recently a featured
hero we had a series of quests where
MODOK tried to take over the contest and
this month of course were featuring
Doctor Strange Marvel contest of
Champions at its core is a fighting game
with fairly simple mechanics you dash in
and out you have three strengths of
attacks and a few special moves but the
team continuously has been working on
adding new variations through new buffs
mechanics events and heroes it keeps the
gameplay fresh for a loyal players a
[Music]
great example tying all of this together
his Ghost Rider who has just added to
the contest he was featured in our
monthly event quest for October called
pandemonium Rising he has a new mechanic
that fits with his character called
judgments that have different effects
depending on how and when you attack
he's also more effective against
villains like Ultron or venom a lot of
work was put into the art and design to
be authentic to the
original character we added a new mode
specific boost for this quest that
players could use to complete the event
content we supported this with a new
splash screen and a new special event
calendar as well just by adding this one
character we can use events and other
small game changes to engage players for
an entire month
so let's break this down a bit more here
are five tips from the Marvel live ops
team on how to run a successful and
engaging LiveOps event the first run a
variety of events variety is definitely
the best way to keep the core gameplay
fresh the goal is to run a variety of
events to engage different types of
players and incentivize different player
behaviors here are some examples we have
arena's running all of the time for
those players who want to compete for
top rewards like four-star featured
heroes or rare upgrade materials but
there are also arenas for mid-range
players for three-star heroes and hero
crystals so it doesn't just cater to the
top veterans but a wide range of players
this was one of the very first events in
the contest and it promoted competition
as well as a deep champion pool in order
to in order to succeed in general events
with competition often do better than
events without a competitive component
so if you're limited on the events that
you can run start with a competitive one
and this is shown in the above stat
players who compete in arenas tend to
complete a lot more fights than those
who only do quests or Alliance events
arenas are more competitive and can
motivate players to participate in more
fights anyone at any phase of the player
life cycle can go on quests these are
maps with a variety of opponents the
player needs to defeat in order to
progress the main story quests are
increasing in difficulty and we also
have monthly event quests with four
difficulty levels players can choose
which version they want to attempt
and earn rewards respective to the
difficulty they complete these come out
monthly kind of like a comic book over
twenty percent of monthly active users
complete at least half of a monthly
quest this might seem like a low
percentage but it includes new players
who are more interested in the main
story we can see from our data that a
constant stream of quest content
improves the retention of our regulars
and it is one of the main reasons we
continue to build them each month
Alliance quests are also a huge part of
our game players work together with
their Alliance to complete a quest map
these maps can have challenging bosses
with much more powerful buffs requiring
coordination from all members of the
Alliance to complete but together they
can earn some of the best upgrade
materials in the game many of the events
are launched server side rather than
built rather than based on a build or
apk the game configurations control
pretty much everything within the game
we use them to update the daily quests
for with additional shards and fragments
earlier this year as well as randomizing
some of the enemies and ambushes we can
create and send messages launch new
quests and events and add new sales or
promotions at any time our daily log in
calendar is controlled in the same way
allowing us to create special event
calendars like the one for Ghost Rider
this gives us a great deal of
flexibility when planning our events and
this speaks back to what Nora was
talking about in avoiding the shark fin
the more control you can give your live
ops team on the server side the more
content and iteration they can do
without major build releases
periodically we also add special event
content often linked to things going on
outside of the game we added factions
during our Civil War event which
coincided with the launch of Captain
America Civil War
players could choose to be on Team
Captain America or team Ironman there
were special quests and
associated with each faction and players
could switch partway through if they
wanted to earn both rewards Chloe's
warriors of awesomeness challenge was a
series of tough battles in an event we
did with Chloe Bennett the actress from
Marvel agents of shield and we've also
done versions of this with ming-na wen
and Clark Gregg and our newest event is
a Doctor Strange dimensional rifts
adding portals to our maps in
conjunction with the release of the
Doctor Strange movie today these special
events attempt to shake up the routine
and have your players change their
behaviors for a short period of time
adapting to the special event and then
adapting back to a pre-event state both
adds variety remember variety isn't just
the type of event you run but also who
is playing some players are very into
the pvp arenas while others are into
being the best at completing the PvE
quest content other players focus on
social events like Alliance quests or
Alliance battles different type of
players are going to gravitate to
different areas of your game a variety
is trying to ensure ever there is
something for everyone now we didn't
launch with all of these elements it
they've been built up over the past two
years each layer we added was built with
the other layers in mind and many of the
later events we added were Alliance
related the social and cooperative
element is an important part of keeping
players interested in your game
cadance events to maximize engagement
major events are planned far in advance
some elements of Marvel contest of
Champions are sketched out all the way
to 2020 we have an amazing backend tool
called sparks that allows us to automate
a lot of the staples of the game so many
of the Alliance and solo events are set
up to require very little of our time to
keep running that allows us to focus on
what variations or additions we can add
so let's talk about an example week in
the game the arena's are constantly
running with feature hero events running
twice a week we release a new hero every
other week so one week it will be for a
brand new hero and the other week it
will be for an older champion the idea
is this gives players who want the new
featured hero they'll get a break every
other week but we still have some
hardcore players that want to win every
single arena no matter what Alliance
events are run with seven three and one
day durations the seven-day summoner
advancement event starts at the same
time every week but the three-day events
are on a 12 day rotation and the one day
event one-day events are on an eight day
rotation these events have different
goals and die and drive different player
behaviors but the staggered rotations
mean that the events will stack up
differently each week Alliance quests
are run every eight days five days on
three days off during this time
alliances complete compete to move up
brackets and earn better rewards the
Alliance versus allies battles are about
two days long and in general alliances
can complete about three a week both of
these modes use champion lockouts that
means champions used in these events
will not be able to be used in other
modes this expands the champion pool a
player needs in order to participate in
all of the content you can't just use
your won best character or won best team
in every mode in the game every month we
add a new event quest that players can
complete this quest usually includes two
or three of the heroes that we plan to
release as a way of introducing them to
the players last month it was Ghost
Rider and this month it will be Mordo
and dr. voodoo our fastest players can
complete heroic and mastery difficulty
versions of this quest in about 6 to 8
hours and if they're the top 100 fastest
they will earn extra
words and a legends title in the game so
we have quite a few players striving for
that goal in addition there are the
special event quests like the Chloe
quest and every day we run daily quests
for upgrade upgrade materials finally
solo events we added these in the past
summer these are shorter events players
can complete on their own with 22 hour
and 7 hour durations these are different
that in that they're random they're
pulled from a pool of possible events
each time an event ends the player won't
know which event will occur next if
you're looking for two events to stack
up like the 22 hour general level up
event and the 7 hour class specific
level up event you're going to have to
keep logging in and checking the game to
see which events are running but if you
find a situation where both are running
you can double up on rewards for the
same amount of effort the schedule is
packed full of things to do each week to
keep even our most voracious players
busy the players who enjoy your game the
most the ones who are most invested are
usually the ones that will complete your
content first keeping them happy with
new content on a consistent basis is a
key factor in retaining those players
[Music]
reward players based on participation
different rewards from different areas
of the game helps spread out player
activity we intentionally made arenas
the best place to earn gold to upgrade
your champions Alliance quests are the
best place to earn late late-game
upgrade materials and Alliance battles
are a great way to earn new heroes
spreading the different currencies and
upgrade materials in two separate events
means players have to spread their
resources and with the champion lockouts
I mentioned earlier this leads to
players needing to upgrade multiple
champions rather than just their top 5
so not only do rewards promote variety
by getting players to participate in
different game modes it also increases
the value of top
champions and upgrade materials some
types of rewards sorry
milestones give players a clear goal to
achieve they know how much effort it
will take to reach milestone 5 and they
can determine if they want to stretch
and reach milestone 6 but the very best
rewards are found in ranked rewards
where the player must compete on a
leaderboard with each other for top
items that way players determine the
ceiling on the effort needed to earn the
rewards as the top players increase in
power so will their top scorers we also
use bracketed rewards this image is from
an old version of our Lions quest
brackets doing well and earning a high
score could move you up to greater
rewards while not doing quite as well
could get you bumped down to a lower
bracket this is an added level
competition as not only do you have to
do well on a given event you have to
continue to do well to maintain your
position all of these are ways you can
reward your players but in general a
combination of milestones and rank
rewards works best milestones work well
with a broad range of players while rank
rewards entice the smaller percentage of
very competitive players we use data
analytics to look at a number at the
number of players who hit each milestone
or rank reward and this helps us make
decisions on tuning and future events
think globally and localize we're
continuing to grow marvel and reach
additional markets by adding more
languages to the game we've added dutch
and norwegian in october and recently
added simplified and traditional chinese
you'll obviously have a hard time
reaching players who do not understand
your events and promotions even if they
love your game with planning and a great
localization team you can greatly
increase the efficiency and reach of
your LiveOps
by improving your localization in
addition to languages you targeted
promotions based on region or holiday
could be very effective we've run
targeted promotions and countries like
Russia Mexico and Brazil and for special
occasions like Ramadan Marvel contest of
Champions runs on one server which means
all countries and time zones usually get
the same events when we added solo
events we made that we made them twenty
two hours and seven hours so that the
start and end times would not be static
so we're 120 two-hour event might start
at 10:00 p.m. the next one will start at
8:00 p.m. and the next one will start at
6:00 p.m. and so on the start and end
times for these events change so that is
more fair to people in different time
zones this is not always possible with
your events but when dealing with global
events is something that you have to
keep in mind collaboration between great
teams LiveOps makes the events happen in
game but we are lucky to have all of
these teams supporting us and I'll
highlight a few these teams on the next
few slides lifecycle marketing as social
media channels can reach players outside
the app and re-engage laughs players by
letting them know there are new exciting
events happening in the game that means
planning events well in advance and
LiveOps working closely with these teams
a combination of life cycle marketing
live ops and data analytics can make
your processes processes more efficient
and improve the effectiveness of your
messaging remember be relevant timely
and succinct have a clear call to action
show value and urgency and segment and
target your players your community
manager and customer service teams are
the ones interacting you're interacting
with your players on a daily basis they
can provide valuable feedback on events
and will be the first to let you know if
there are issues when we talk about
regulars we're talking about long term
active players
with a love for your game and these
teams help ensure your players become
regulars teams helping extend your reach
are also important marketing and
business development help us work with
our partners like Marvel and Google Play
increasing user acquisition through
Google Play featuring or collaborations
with Marvel our very very are very
beneficial and often require live off
support we have had some of our team
recently at New York comic-con to meet
with players and do interviews there was
a giant booth in the Marvel area and we
set up a special event battle and gave
prizes from a prize wheel it was great
for the team to interact with players in
that way I've heard that some of the
players spent most of their day
repeatedly coming back to beat the quest
so they could take additional spins on
that prize wheel and finally a talented
development team paired with insightful
analytics can create powerful results
even if it's something as simple as
improving your tutorial completion rate
by 1% if you keep improving small
percentages they will add up to big
returns the data science team is
embedded with live ops their dashboards
provide us with up-to-date KPIs like
retention engagement and player event
participation whenever we have a
question we can go to them and get an
answer when we create new events it's
often a joint effort between the design
live ops and data teams to build and
tune the event before it goes live live
offs also works closely with the design
team on any new features ensuring that
the launch of the feature goes smoothly
but as any developer with a live game
can tell you things don't always go
smoothly so I'm going to tell a short
story about the Yolo incident so one
Friday evening we were surprised to see
a bright orange banner appear in the
game with one word Yolo
and it seems that there was an
incredibly rare bug that that caused a
test message to be sent as an
announcement rather than a general chat
message so all the players in the game
are now looking at the words Yolo in
bright letters at the top of their
screen and I am so so thankful that it
was Yolo and not any number of possible
other words or phrases that we could
have used for a test message the live
ops team quickly pulled down the message
the QA team found the problem almost
immediately and our tools our tools team
fixed the issue in under an hour our
community team quickly messaged out that
to our community that it was our mistake
and by the next morning an artist had
created this wonderful image which we
posted on our Facebook social media page
where it became one of our most liked
images we were we were able to quickly
turn a negative into a positive
thanks to the whole team jumping on the
issue so here's an extra bonus tip
versatile tools these are some things
you want in your back-end tools
flexibility you want to create a tool
that can build a lot of variations so
that you can iterate on your events also
building in features that allow you to
target groups of players can help
optimize your promotions and sales data
tracking if you don't track and log your
events you're going to have a harder
time figuring out what went right or
what went wrong willingness to iterate
and this isn't just about iterating on
your events you need to iterate and
improve your tools so that you can
create more sophisticated events and
promotions and one last point scheduling
and automation every December the studio
goat the studio shuts down between
Christmas and New Year's but rather than
that be a slow period where not much is
happening in the game Christmas is one
of our busiest times of the year so to
do this we built all of the
events ahead of time before the break
then we just push the events when needed
and ensure everything runs smoothly if
there are any issues we can fix them all
server-side without support from the
rest of the development team by building
this kind of tool you can continue to
launch content to your players in
between builds but it requires an
upfront investment and a commitment to
maintain it we're constantly tweaking
and building upon our events as the game
ages so do the players and their
champion teams our data team provides us
with metrics that help us analyze
players so we can make informed
decisions on with our events and our
rewards so when we're building events we
start with a goal what are we trying to
accomplish with this event
what kind of KPIs can we use to measure
can we build it without client support
if support is needed we can see if we
can see if we can get it added to the
product backlog but if we can build it
we launch it and we analyze how it does
did it do well or not why how can it be
improved if the event goes really well
is there a way to permanently add this
event to the game or build upon it with
additional development support by adding
more flexibility and control into your
tool you can increase live office
ability to iterate and improve your
events so to recap run a variety of run
a variety of events competitive and
social ones cadence your events to
maximize engagement reward players based
on participation think globally and
localize invest in talented teams and
communicate and of course invest in
back-end tools one final example to wrap
this all up is the new Doctor Strange
event players will earn currency called
dimensional shards by participating in
different events over the next five week
period the more they participate the
more shards they'll earn
using this currency they can open up new
dimensional rifts which are limited time
quests with very valuable rewards they
can choose when they want to open these
rifts so it they aren't locked to any
start or end time and this new event is
the reserve is the result of Hart the
hard work of countless talented people
all working together so that the live
ops team just has to hit a button and
launch the event thank you
[Applause]